la majorité la France retient son
souffle avant la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel on l'a dit sur la
réforme des retraites qu'est-ce que vous
donc l'une des composantes de la
majorité qui a parfois aussi une musique
un petit peu différente à faire entendre
qu'est-ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui
effectivement le pays est suspendu à ses
décisions c'est pas la première fois les
les avis du Conseil constitutionnel sont
importants sur beaucoup de textes
d'ailleurs beaucoup de projets loi de
finances chaque année
là c'est effectivement crucial et c'est
très important en fait
je pense que il y aura deux aspects soit
le Conseil constitutionnel considère que
en la forme le texte doit être
censurée en quelque sorte pourquoi parce
que il y a eu le 47 ans il y a eu
l'article 38 du Règlement au Sénat il y
a eu l'article 44 enfin plus de 49.3
pour terminer donc ce serait logique
qu'il soit sur je dis pas ça je pense
que
sur la sincérité sur la clarté ce qui
ont les grands principes qui pourraient
poser problème je pense qu'on n'y est
pas et que le Conseil constitutionnel
peut être amené à censurer quelques
mesures qui pourraient être considéré ce
qu'on appelle comme des cavaliers
législatifs c'est-à-dire par exemple la
mise en place d'un index senium le CDI
senior il y a quelques points qui
pourraient être mais qui pourront tout à
fait être réétudiés dans une analyse
plus globale du texte est-ce que vous
seriez satisfait que le Conseil
constitutionnel donne son feu vert au
référendum d'initiatives partagées c'est
une demande de la gauche est-ce que ce
serait un progrès selon vous ce qui a
été demandé dans le cas du réforme des
initiative partagée c'est simplement de
dire est-ce que c'est 62 ans le principe
de l'âge de départ à la retraite plutôt
que 64 ça manque un peu de densité après
c'est un outil de démocratique il faut
respecter on verra bien mais vous seriez
politiquement satisfait que le je pense
qu'on a qu'on a eu un texte qui me
semble
utile
j'ai pas la grande loi de sur la grande
réforme des retraites et c'est un texte
utile et nécessaire pour l'équilibre
financier donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
ait ce processus d'aller jusqu'au bout
de ce texte nous aurions souhaité nous
aller au vote vous savez bon on a on a
eu le 49-3 qui est une forme de vote par
mais on sent des regrets on sera une
amertume quand même bien sûr que je
souhaitais moi qu'on puisse que le
Parlement et notamment l'Assemblée
nationale puisse voter sur ce texte il y
a eu un vote puisque la motion de
censure n'a pas été et n'a donc pas
annulé le texte donc il y a eu un vote
on peut pas on peut pas le nier
maintenant je pense qu'on a il faut
qu'on avance il faut qu'on avance est-ce
que c'est la fin de l'histoire Jean-Paul
Mattei est-ce que lorsque si c'est le
cas la loi aura été validée par le
Conseil constitutionnel et encore une
fois si c'est le cas et bien la réforme
s'appliquera pour les prochaines années
il y a pas de clause de revoyure
justement nous groupes démocrates
modernes et indépendant on a insisté sur
la mise en place d'une clause de
revoyure qui était initialement dans le
projet dans la fameuse article 7 qui est
maintenant devenu l'article 10 dans le
nouveau texte et qui prévoit qu'il y
aura la remise d'un rapport au 1er
octobre 2027 et ce rapport sera débattu
à la fois dans la loi ça c'est dans la
loi et il sera tout à fait possible à ce
moment-là de se saisir de cette question
et je rappelle que le fameux âge de 64
ans en 2027 on sera pas à 64 ans puisque
l'application la loi s'applique dans le
temps et ce n'est pas des faits immédiat
on a une projection qui me semble
nécessaire et donc moi pour moi et
j'invite les forces syndicales à
réfléchir sur ce sujet à se saisir de
cette possibilité de travailler sur
l'application la loi voir si les
équilibres sont bien respectés et ça
veut dire on entend dans ce que vous
dites que finalement 64 ans c'est pas
sûr non je sais presque ce que vous
sembler
64 ans est une forme de sécurité
financière pour
justifier l'équilibre financier de cette
réforme mais ça n'empêche que rien n'est
fermé vous savez sur des hypothèses sur
des hypothèses de taux de chômage de
croissance auquel bâti un peu ce texte
c'est des choses qui sont de toute façon
variable et donc dans le temps on sait
bien que ces réformes de retard dans les
revient souvent c'est pas quelque chose
de figé et je crois que c'est important
ce que vous disiez ça veut dire que
l'histoire n'est pas écrite sur ces
encore une fois sur l'aboutissement
et le maintien des retraites répartition
parce que c'est le principe même les
cotisants d'aujourd'hui paix pour les
retraités d'aujourd'hui ça me semble
excessivement important de maintenir ses
équilibres mais on ne s'interdit rien
sur la réflexion de l'évolution de ce
texte et à mon avis il y a plein
d'occasions de se retrouver avec les
partenaires sociaux pour travailler
ensemble sur ces sujets de fonds et ça
va donner du grain à moudre justement
c'est partenaires sociaux c'est
syndicats qui quel que soit la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel ce soir pour
la plupart d'entre eux la CFDT une
discours un petit peu différent disent
que le combat va continuer contre cette
réforme il y a plusieurs types de
combats il y a le combat en disant
retrait de la réforme bon nous étions
nous le groupe favorable à cette réforme
encore une fois la réforme du siècle
mais ce qui semble nécessaire ça
n'empêche ça n'empêche que aujourd'hui
les syndicats les partenaires sociaux
ont prouvé lorsqu'ils sont venus dans
d'autres domaines qui étaient capables
de se mettre d'accord sur certains
sujets sur votre plateau tout à l'heure
j'entendais qu'on évoquait la corne
nationale interprofessionnel sur le
partage de la valeur également sur
l'économie verte qui est adopté les
partenaires sociaux ont su trouver les
chemins pour trouver des solutions par
exemple cet accord sur le partage de la
valeur est très riche 36 articles très
très riches et dense mais pardon de
revenir sur la réforme des retraites
lorsque Laurent Berger avait il y a
quelques jours quelques semaines évoqué
la nécessité d'une médiation le
gouvernement avait fermé la porte et
vous vous aviez dit mais oui ce serait
peut-être une bonne solution qui a
vraiment deux lignes au sein de
l'exécutif je pense que le moment est
venu de se mettre autour d'une table de
travailler pour moi l'histoire n'est pas
terminée loin de là on peut avoir une
réflexion à long terme sur les réformes
et la notion d'une loi travail qui
prendra en compte certains sujets
notamment sur le temps de travail ça je
pense que toutes les pistes sont
ouvertes il faut qu'on les saisisse
aujourd'hui concrètement on voyait les
syndicats reçus à Matignon il y a
quelques jours c'est bloqué ils sont
venus la réunion a tourné court parce
que ça bloque sur la question des 64 ans
ça vous le voyez vous êtes encore une
fois membre de la majorité il y a pas de
dialogue aujourd'hui il y a aucune
ouverture je dirais les 64 ans il est
des deux côtés et à la fois dit nous
c'est c'est une garantie de l'équilibre
financier de l'autre côté les syndicats
on voit bien avec l'application de la
réforme Touraine que dans certains cas
on arrivait à 64 ans beaucoup de
retraites même certains c'est 67 ans il
faut aussi parler de retraite complète
mais là c'est la voix et ça ne passe pas
voilà il faut qu'on se pose et qu'on une
réflexion globale je crois que ce sont
les bonnes pistes à prendre il y a il y
aura un an dans quelques jours
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été réélu
finalement quel bilan vous tirez de
cette première année pour le moins
mouvementé sans majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale comment on va faire comment
vous allez faire pour tenir 4 ans dans
ces conditions et pour gouverner moi je
crois qu'il faut qu'on se projette sur
des textes importants il y aura
peut-être la loi travail il y a
également une loi sur le logement sur la
santé sur le ciel qui me risque il faut
qu'on ait des textes me semble-t-il qui
ne projette on a vécu pendant le dernier
quinquennat et même ce quinquennat des
des textes beaucoup en défensif pour
répondre à une crise ça a été les gilets
jaunes ça a été la crise sanitaire ça a
été la guerre mondiale des efforts aux
Français et d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
cas on s'est retrouvés la loi par
exemple le finance rectificatif sur le
pouvoir d'achat on a retrouvé une
majorité 149,3 on a adopté des textes
149 donc il faut en quelque sorte si on
vous entend bien gouverner avec des
textes qui parce que la loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'était comme son nom
l'indique plus de pouvoir d'achat pour
les Français donc des textes qui font
plutôt plaisir aux électeurs il faut
qu'on soit aussi en responsabilité parce
que plutôt que demander de des moyens
notre mouvement est très attaché aux
équilibre financiers et notamment
finances publiques et éviter le dérapage
donc on sera excessivement vigilant donc
il faut qu'on réfléchisse à je dirais
d'autres vecteurs et emballer en quelque
sorte avec des belles réformes qui
puissent aller essayer d'élargir notre
majorité relative on entendait la
chronique d'Axel de Tarlet avant le
journal la question du partage des
richesses a été au cœur de la
contestation est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut rester dans le statu quo
aujourd'hui fiscal je dis cela parce que
vous aviez défendu une taxe sur les
super dividendes est-ce qu'il faut la
mettre en place est-ce que vous allez
revenir à la charge là dessus sur l'ISF
on ne bouge pas quel est votre sentiment
moi je crois qu'il faut être lucide
les revenus du travail
contribue plus au budget de l'État que
les revenus du capital donc on a un
sujet un sujet de et vous le déplorez je
le déplore je pense qu'il faut qu'on se
pose la bonne question nous sommes
actuellement en train d'avoir une
mission
dans le cas de la commission des
finances au Parlement sur la réforme de
la fiscalité du patrimoine je crois
qu'il faut qu'on mette tout à plat et
qu'on réfléchisse on a maintenant sur
les super dividendes c'était allé
chercher les dividendes donc qui sont
distribués et qui sont c'est pas un
bénéfice qui sort de l'entreprise alors
qui certes nécessaires pour rémunir les
actionnaires mais qui est qui était un
symbole et qui permettait en quelque
sorte de rééquilibrer donner un signe
que les gens qui ont la chance d'avoir
des revenus
vous savez je ne lâche rien et que de
toute façon ça sera ça reviendra sur la
table dans le cas soit du PLF soit d'un
texte autonome sur sur ce sujet sur les
super dividendes donc on a entendu ce
matin votre loyauté mais aussi votre
singularité au sein de la majorité je
vous remercie Jean-Paul Mattei président
du groupe modem à l'Assemblée nationale
et c'est la suite de téléporteur merci
beaucoup